hey everyone welcome back my name is
mehul and in this video we'll be doing a
complete month stack application
development using all the four later
technologies mongodb express react and
node.js so this is what monstaq is these
are four technologies which you can use
to develop a full application it's a
convention people say moan stack but
pretty much you would use a lot of other
technologies as well so in this video i
want to just go ahead and show you how
you can develop a full complete
application
only using monstack let's go if you're
new here consider subscribing because
i'll be adding more such interactive
content and things which you can do here
so make sure you like and subscribe to
this video and let's just go ahead and
see how we can build ammon stack
application okay so right now you can
see on my screen that we have a simple
text editor and that's it i have just
this folder we have index.js and that's
it that's there's nothing else
so we're going to be starting from the
very scratch in this video and taking a
look at every single part of the
application so the first things first
we know that mon stack is [ __ ] plus
express
plus react plus node now to be honest
express plus node thing is fine because
if you're using express it doesn't make
a lot of sense because if you're using
express you're automatically using
node.js it's kind of redundant but it's
okay we'll start with setting up a
simple react app because that can also
run standalone but what you have to
remember is when development inside
development you would have a node.js
server plus a react server running right
but when you are running this in
production you will have a node.js
server but you will have static react
files that is the difference between
development and the production thing and
we'll see how we can combine them in the
production video and in when we are
deploying this on the cloud but for the
development part let's just stick with
this setup right here this means clearly
we need two things the first thing is
node.js server and the second thing is
react server or the react project so
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna go ahead
and create a directory here called
server and this will just contain our
server stuff and i'm also gonna move
this index to
server right i'm gonna create another
directory called app or client or
whatever you want to name but we want
this to be a react project so i'm going
to initialize this with npx create
the act app and this would be just
client right
so
this just initializes it with the
default react bundle and installing
packages and stuff all right so you can
see now inside our client folder we have
package.jsonyarn.log file which means we
are running yarn as the package manager
if you see a package dash locked or json
file it's completely fine that means
you're using npm if you write npm like
this in your terminal and do an npm
version if this happens this appears a
six or seven or whatever version you
have at the moment that's fine if you
are using yarn that is also fine these
are both package managers
and at least yarn version one is
basically the similar thing as npm
version whatever you are running six
seven eight so we have this client set
up now what i want to do is split my
terminal here real quick and i want to
go ahead and start
this
project by saying yarn
start because this is going to start our
client project on port number 3000 by
default right so it opens it up in the
browser it will just compile the stuff
like you know like i said this is the
react server which i was talking about
when you're doing this on production
when you're deploying this on a real
website you will obviously not have a
react server running
because react is just html css and
javascript right at the end of the day
react is just javascript and the reason
you need this server is because the app
needs a transpilation step the jsx which
you write the modern javascript syntax
which you write that needs a
transpilation step so babel webpack all
this stuff is sitting in the server and
doing that as you type like the hot
reloading stuff and without actually
refreshing anything all that stuff
happens but the moment that happens you
can see that on the screen and it
refreshes and all that things but you
don't necessarily need that on a
production server so anyway let's just
keep going so we have our react app up
and ready what we want to do next is
also have our server some sort of you
know in place so of the month stack we
have already covered the r part so it's
the main type
and
so let's just go ahead and start with
our main time which is basically going
to be very simple first of all we need
to initialize the project because this
is a node project so we can just say
yarn in it if you're using npm you can
say npm in it i'm just going to keep the
default options you can also specify a
dash y here but anyway now you can see
we also have a package.json file here
and let me just actually copy this whole
thing and
save it inside here all right so you can
see we basically have node installed on
our system right i did not talk about
that because i was assuming that
everyone has not installed but if you
don't have it i have a bunch of videos
probably i will link it somewhere here
in the cards at the top right or left
showing you how you can install node.js
but once you have done that you will be
able to see that it's very easy to set
up a project now the next thing you need
to do is install express now express is
a framework e stands for express and
express is just a node.js framework
which allows your application the server
application to have easier looking
syntax i mean you can technically still
do all of the stuff we do in express in
node but it's just easy on ice right
it's easy to do so let's just start with
yarn again yarn out express and what
this will do is this will install the
express.js package inside of our server
folder okay so the moment we do that
you're going to be seeing that inside
package.json we have this but we're
going to be adding another server called
yarn add node mod
so just like you can see that we have
react server running which will reflect
let's say if i go to this app.jsx and
say
go down right here and take a look you
can see it updates automatically right
similarly we can do a similar thing with
servers using node mono where nodemon
would just restart the node.js process
if there is any change okay so now you
can see we also have node mod installed
and what i'm going to do more is i'm
going to add a script here called dev so
this script just means that whenever i
write yarn dev or npx dev or npm run dev
this should happen
what is that that is nodemon index.js
right
right yarn dev and you can see it runs
nodemod index.js
clean exit waiting for changes before
restart because obviously there is no
change yet let's just go ahead now and
take a look at how we can write our
express server real quick i'm going to
go ahead and say const app or const
express is a require express and once
you have express you need to call this
as a function to actually initialize a
new application then you can specify
some routes like
hello for example
and this accepts a request on a response
object which can be used to determine
what headers the client has passed or
what you want to say to client in this
case i'm just going to say hello world
like this right and the final thing you
need to do is also start a server
because right now you can see nodemon
just runs your node file and exits
because there is no long running process
and servers are long running process so
what you want to do is say app dot
listen
and let's say i want to listen to port
number 1337 right and we can also say
something like console.log server
started
on one right just just a quick notice
which you can see in the console now
what you can see is if you go to
localhost1337
slash let's say hello which which is our
defined route you can see we get hello
world
now remember we have two servers running
at the moment the first one is the react
server which is a fake server because we
don't need this in production and the
second one is the node server which we
will need in the production right but
for now we will develop it as if we are
having two different servers right in
production probably this page would be
served right here automatically right
you can do that still even in this phase
but it will require a lot of patching
and you will lose a bunch of features
like auto reloading and stuff like that
all right let's just go ahead and create
a very simple app which
handles login registration and setting
up a favorite quote inside the dashboard
right that's all that will be so what we
want to do first things first is we want
to go ahead and clean up this mess right
here and let's say this is just
registration area for us right so i'm
going to say h1 register and i'm not
going to focus at all
on the
layout or the css part because the
monster actually we just want to cover
how the core functionality works and you
know github co-pilot will be really
really helpful here let's see if it can
help first name nope i don't want a lot
of stuff so we can just stick to maybe
name
email
and
password right and what we want to do is
really create them as state variables
all right so now you can see i imported
use state from here and set up the basic
boilerplate template which is just
having these
variables as the state variables and
having name email and password as a
theme as these things and you can see
now this works absolutely fine right we
have a pretty much working form and you
can just inject a bunch of html here if
you would like and a final button so you
can say input type summit and then value
register
and that's it
now you can see that we have let's just
go ahead and
also give this a vr but you can see that
we have this other form so whenever i
submit this
i mean after having
the right data you can see it redirects
me to a page so in order to change that
behavior we'll have a method of we don't
exactly need a method we can just say on
summit and we can specify a register
user
now right here this is the very first
point when our front end is going to
communicate with the back end right and
we can make this an asynchronous
function and what we want to do is we
want to say that hey
go ahead and fetch something like this
which called your copilot is helping me
already with so this is localhost one
three three seven remember because we
are running this on port number one from
three seven and we're gonna have an api
slash register route let's see
where what we're gonna do is pass the
body
as the following object json.string
name email and password right so once we
do that you're gonna be seeing that we
just send this to the backend but we
also need to tell the backend that hey
we are gonna send this as a content type
of application json and why that is
necessary that is necessary because
there are a lot of content types you can
send this in a bunch of ways you can
send this as a binary data you can send
this as url encoded and stuff like this
but the simplest is for text-based data
at least is json so i'm going to go
ahead and wait for the response
and then we are also going to try to
convert it into json like this and i'm
just going to console log this data
right here right so this actually ends
our first part in which we just have to
go ahead
and create a link between the front end
and the back end so now if i have
something like this register
and of course we need to do one more
thing is
the event which we get here we need to
set event dot prevent default
why do we need to do this because right
here you can see forms have a default
behavior of refreshing or redirecting to
that particular page which you have
specified as an action
let's say this is our email
register and you can see that we get
failed to fetch because again we are
missing one thing that we need a method
here of post
register again and you can see now we
get standard errors which is fine we'll
fix this in
server now all right so the first thing
we need to do here is gonna be
actually setting up
our course policy for the local
development part i mean you can do it
for local itself it's fine but what you
want to do is first of all terminate
your server and install a package known
as yarn
add
course and the reason you want to add
course package is because you see this
error access to fetch at this from
origin this has been blocked by course
policy right so you're gonna you're
gonna have this error anyway even if you
create your server if you don't have the
correct course configuration now
remember that this page ideally this
react page ideally would be served by
the node.js same port itself right the
same server the same port itself so you
probably don't need course on production
but that is required when you're
developing at least because browsers are
weird and they require all sorts of
security measures and causes one of the
security measures right so you need to
do that so once you have that you just
have to import
it via required
course and just say that this course is
a middleware now middleware is just a
function which manipulates the response
and in most of the cases just passes it
to the next function right so it just
says that hey
this course what this does internally is
this it just sets correct headers on the
response so that chrome allows you to
communicate with a cross origin and why
this is a cross origin because of the
different ports right if they were all
the same ports localhost 1337 then it
will not be a cross solution
so that is fine let's just
start our server again by
let's say you don't want nope
beyond diff right
so once we do that and refresh or maybe
even not even refresh you can see right
here we no longer get the course error
but actually uh unexpected greater than
symbol or less than in json that is
because we are receiving just the wrong
response at the moment so if you go
right here you can see that we get the
response all right so now it's time to
set up handler called app.post api
register now the first thing we want to
do is of course we can just say
rest.json status okay but how do we get
the body here which the user is passing
because if you do something like
console.org request.body you're going to
see that when i click on register we
pretty much get undefined here in the
console right so that means we are not
receiving the body yet we are but that
is not available at least on the request
or body
syntax right here so the reason for this
is because this route does not know that
you are passing in json right and in
order to let express know that hey we're
gonna be using json a lot to pass you
know to pass the body what you also want
to do is you want to use an
express.json as the middleware so what
this does is that it says to express
that hey we're going to be going ahead
and you should be going ahead and pass
anything which comes as body into json
right that's that's all it does and also
like you know populate the body in the
first place because if it does not it's
just undefined anyway so once we do that
hit on register
now you can see we get status okay as
the response as well as this data which
we got from the front end right so that
is cool okay so we are basically done
with express and node here and the only
thing we need to do is link [ __ ] now
right so the way we're going to be doing
that is by actually installing another
package called mongoose
and mongoose allows us to define models
and work with mongodb as well through it
right so mongoose can be as a you know
it's an orm which allows you to connect
to mongodb but it can be a bit useful
for data validation and just schema
validation as well i'm going to be
creating a folder here called models
i'm going to be starting with
user.model.js
or you know user.js whatever you want to
do so what you want to do is you want to
get mongoose first by saying require
mongoose like this and you want to
define a model so you want to say my
user model is something like new
mongoose dot schema
and it should be having a property
called name which is of type string and
this is required property as well
require true you can say email type
string required to and password require
you know github co-pilot just taking
over the world we don't want to create
an ad we just want a
port let's say this is of type string
and it's probably not required right and
all we need to do is we want to say that
the
collection
of this model is user data for example
this is the name of the collection in
the mongodb database which you're
creating next we create a model by
saying mongoose.model
give it a name like user data or
something and which is the schema
associated with it that is the user and
then finally you just say export not
export default but module dot exports
because we are in still in common js
world i should have probably done this
in es6 modules but anyway we'll probably
do it sometime
later on who's this model right here so
this model just allows us to directly
access and interact with mongoose the
next thing which you want to do is also
import mongoose
right here with us
and the reason for this is because we
want to connect to mongoose before
anything happens right and the good
thing with mongoose is although this
mongoose.connect returns as a promise
but mongoose internally
cues that is it puts it in a queue of
things to do if the connection is not
ready yet so you can technically just
connect it in a synchronous way and just
you know start using it anywhere you
like so what you want to do is specify a
function specify a string here
connection string in my case i'm just
running a localhost mongodb let me just
see if my mongodb is running not really
so i'm just going to start my docker for
you you would have to install mongodb on
your system again it is pretty
straightforward just go to google write
mongodb go to this mongodb website
download the start do or start free or
download the community server edition
and just start it by yourself i think if
you do
go to get started here now you don't
need to
probably create an account
let's see mongodb
download yeah you want the community
download version and once you download
it it'll install it open it it'll
automatically be started on port 27017
okay so once that is done you should be
able to write something like mongodb
27017 and the name of the database and
the good thing about mongodb is or bad
thing depending on how you see it that
you can pretty much specify the database
name and collections right away inside
the code and automatically create it if
not present i can just say this as full
non-stack
video for example
and that's it it'll automatically create
this database and then when we use this
user model it will automatically create
this user data collection all right so
once we have this all we need to do is
actually we can actually go ahead in the
model and do one more thing we can say
the email address is also unique so what
this would do is this will create an
index in mongodb which will be on unique
in a status there would not be a
duplicate value for email or it will
just throw us an error right so what we
want to do is we want to convert this
into an async function and throw it
inside a try catch so we want to say
okay rest.json error is fine but we also
want to say let's see what codepilot has
to offer yep that is pretty much it that
is pretty much it that's what we want to
do but it's always a good practice to
not just arbitrary use user data but
instead do something like this right
because now i know that hey i'm in
control right what goes into the
database and yep i think that's all we
are getting from the user side right uh
name email password yep that is true
and then we finally say
rest.json status okay right otherwise
inside catch if we are arriving we know
that
the record is already found it is
duplicate so we can just say status
error
and then error is duplicate email right
something like this you can perform more
validation here depending on maybe like
your name should be certain characters
your email should be certain characters
and so on but this is like the bare
minimum version you should do in order
to handle the errors as well okay so
once that is done with us let's just
quickly go ahead and create a login
route as well and maybe actually let's
just say yeah i think we can just go
ahead and create a login route
right here what we'll say
is
instead of user.create we want
user.find1
with an email of
request.body.email and
password of request.body.password
and this is actually a bad practice to
store passwords in plain text which will
shortly cover how we should fix this but
we can just say that if we have a user
right here and we can just remove try
catch from here because it will not fail
if we have a user until unless your
mongodb connection itself fails but yeah
then we just say return rest.json data's
okay and then user true for example
we'll return some sort of authentication
information here ideally
else what you want to do is just return
restore json error and user false that's
it all right i think we have the bare
bones code ready with us we can start it
with nodemon no yarn def
and once we do that you can see we get
some mongodb warnings it needs some new
flags here which is fine i mean they're
just warnings at the moment
but what you can do now is go back right
here and you can start with let's say a
at the rate b dot c
right and maybe
let's say it's the
name and the password so when i register
now you can see that we get a duplicate
email which is probably not we were
expecting so let's just debug
what is going wrong by also console
logging the error
right so now if we register
go to the console
you can see that we have an error saying
user is not defined very well because we
probably did not import this model so
what we want to do is also import it
from
models
user.model
right
and of course this would be screaming
loud if you were using typescript that
is one of the reasons i like typescript
of one of the many reasons i should
rather say
yeah you can see now we get status okay
and here also we get the console.log if
i try to create this user again then we
will actually get a status error right
which is now correct in this case in
this case you can see the error which we
get from mongodb
is right here you can
you cannot actually see it very well
because the error dot message is kind of
hidden here which is like this is the
error message
right but yeah i mean you can
technically just take out this error
message and detect if this is truly an
error of duplicate key or not because
just use just like you saw in any other
case it will return you this error so
it's not very tight but anyway that's
fine that's fine to start okay so we are
very close to creating our basic full
stack application here we have a
registered user let's just go ahead and
create a simple login page as well i'm
going to say login.js
and it's not going to contain name but
pretty much everything else it will be
login it will be login user
and the only change which we need right
here
is saying that this is api login
we don't have the name we only have
email and
password and
we also don't have this thing right here
right so
you can see
rest of the stuff is pretty much
the same all right so the next step is
once we have this login page actually
let's just go ahead and organize this in
a better way so we're going to be saying
this as pages and let's say i move this
inside as
um
register
let's do a little bit of next share
style things login
not exactly but
you know
and
we can do create root but i think we
have not installed react 18 yet here so
it's fine we can just keep it at render
we can remove this and i have just
removed some unnecessary files it looks
a bit cleaner now you can see we have an
app which is being imported from the
wrong place so what i'm gonna do is
create an app component and we're gonna
also be using react router now right so
in order to provide routing on the front
end we'll be doing what i'm gonna say as
a react router dom so this package right
here allows us to perform react routing
that means different different pages
with the help of
client-side routing and finally when we
deploy it inside node.js project as a
static files we will still be doing
client-side routing but that will be
also be supported via server side we'll
see when that happens but anyway for now
let's just import react from react and
i'm just going to say app is a
function
which returns us this whole
thing right so this thing right here is
going to be
imported from the app router dom
which co-pilot was already able to guess
and this would be browser router right
so
this browser router just provides us
with that functionality
we should also import something known as
route
which is going to be
something like path this component this
should be actually passed login
component login and this should be an
exact match
and similar thing for register
and finally we will also import these
two components from
pages and
login
and
register okay i think it makes sense so
far so now if i go ahead and export this
export default app you're gonna be able
to see
that let's see we need to remove the css
file imports i think
and once you do that it should work fine
so now if i go ahead and take a look
right here if i refresh nothing happens
because we don't have any route but if i
go to login we get the login route and
if i go to register we get the register
output
awesome
so now once again now let me just
refresh this once
what i want to do is inside of login
part we already have done most of the
work which needs to be done in order to
send the data on the backend
inside our index.js file inside backend
we will also create a login endpoint
which will do the similar thing but
it pretty much does nothing at the point
so let's just go ahead and create a new
user called admin administrator
admin.com
and the same password so once i register
this i get a status of okay
if i go to login now if i try this
register this you can see we get status
okay and use it true because my password
was fine if i write triple f5 here
you see we get user faults because my
password was wrong so that is fine but
how do we add authentication to this now
in order to add authentication what i'm
going to do is i'm going to add another
package called json web token
and what this package would allow us to
do is it will allow us to
sign jwd tokens and retrieve them and
basically work with them and i have
installed this on the client side but
actually
it makes more sense to install it on the
server side so i'm going to say yarn
json web token on the server directory
as well
so what this means is that we're going
to be importing this first of all jwt is
required json with token
this jwt right here can allow us to
create a special token which only we can
create and can allow us to determine
that hey this user is legit right so we
know that if the user account exists we
can send the user a jw token so we can
say token is jwt dot
sign and what this is
as far as i remember the yeah
secret of the private key is the second
thing so we
our secret is secret one two three but
ideally your secret should be way way
way secure and the sign thing right here
is just the payload which you want to
sign right in this case i just want to
have
an email
request.body
dot email right here
and probably their name as well if you
would want
uh user dot name for example and for the
sake of
consistency you can also stick with user
dot email and what you finally do is you
just send this token down the wire now
what will happen is that when you log in
if you go ahead and actually
remove the fives if you go ahead you
will see that you receive a token like
this
now what this token is pretty much
it's nothing it's just a base64 encoded
variant of your payload with certain
security embedded and the way you know
it is that you see these two full stops
right here and i'm just telling you
about jwt right now this is a standard
example of jw token this jwt token has
this payload which is in between of
these two dots and this thing right here
is base64 encoding and if i try to
decode this with a to b
what you will see
is that this is a json
payload right with the fields which we
passed name admin email this and also uh
you know a creation time of the token uh
specified by the jwt library itself
right if you just go ahead and try to do
it
you will see that this is actually the
time of creation of this token okay
anyway once we have this pretty much no
one can modify this information because
if they do that token gets distorted
you know it will not pass the server
side check so it's fine i mean we can
just go ahead and use it
right right there so what we can do once
we have done that is we can go ahead and
inside of our login app
we can say
if
data dot
user
exists
then we can say alert login
successful
else alert please check
your username and password
right
once the login is successful
you may very well just
send them at
a code page right
window.location.org
so what this will do is
it will allow us to create another route
here
code.js where we can just show the code
of the user which they have right
i'm going to have a code page here
saying something like
hello world for example and what we want
to do is we want to have the user code
being shown here right
or let's just name this dashboard
instead of code
and this should also be
this should also be dashboard
and one more thing which is we can just
name this as login okay also let's just
go ahead and define the route for this
real quick so dashboard
dashboard
and import
dashboard like this
and one more thing which you can do is
inside dashboard we need to verify the
user is logged in right so we're going
to be writing a use effect hook and
we're going to be saying
that hey
if we are not able to find that jwd
token with us so i'm just going to say
jwt from json token because we also
installed it here
i can say uh my token is first of all we
get it from local storage which again
something we have to see if we have
token then user is jw decode token which
is like copilot is doing all this stuff
and we can say if
user
does not exist
that means something went wrong
uh
yeah i mean this kind of works right
which co-pilot is writing instead what
we can do is make use of
use history hook from react router
use this tree
and once we do that you will be able to
see that we can just say history dot
replace
and login right here
so this performs a check
and another check which we need to do in
fact is that if user does not exist
if user does exist what we want to do is
perform this request to the backend and
see if we can populate the code so we
can just say populate code right here
and what this will do is that this will
be a function
like this which could be async and what
we can do is just say await fetch
api slash code
cons data is equal to api slash code and
we can just say
headers
we are just including this in the
headers x axis token instead of cookies
and we can just say
you know what we did here local storage
dot get item of token
now quick recap of what we are doing
here is that before after just after
this component mounts we run this use
effect only once if we found the token
that's well and good
you know that's well and good we just
populate the code by giving an http
request to slash api slash code which
should be actually
localhost1337 slash api code
if not then we redirect the user to
the history dot replace thing off login
right okay so once we have the code with
us what we can say this could be just
request and data is request.json
we can just say console.log of data
right now um just to see what we are
getting right so the next thing which
you want to do is the right inside of
our register page
we also want to say if data.status is
okay
then i just navigate it to the login
page right so i can just say
history.push
login
not push state but actually push and
this history right here is again
a hook which is provided by
use react router. library right
all right so so far what we have is if i
go ahead
and create another account
let's say
mabel
payment
the same password we get redirected to
the login page
and if i have this as the login thing
you can see i get login successful click
on ok and i get redirected to slash
dashboard which just says me hello world
at the moment right and inside of
console we see nothing happening instead
of networks also nothing happening
so
that is that is probably not good
because yeah that nothing happens
because we don't have the token store
so what we want to do at login is the
moment we get this token we also want to
store it so i want to say local storage
or set item
token is data.user right because this
will now allow us to
send this token over and over again so
let's just perform the login one more
time
click login and now you would be able to
see that our local storage includes not
this one actually this is from
some
other project
but if i do a locals let's just go ahead
and do it one more time
and let's say
login
number
successful and you can see right here we
have our token in place right and you
can also see we get an error that 404
not found so let's just go ahead and
create this api now at the back end so
what i'm going to do is
go to my index.js again
create a new endpoint and remember this
endpoint was get it was not post
so we will just keep it get like this
but what i'll do is i'll say
my token first of all is request.header
x-axis token right because we want to
perform authentication first so
i'm going to say const decoded is
jwt.verify and then token and then
secret123 which was the actual secret
which i wrote right this just verifies
synchronously you can also pass this as
a call back if you would like
uh synchronously this verifies if your
token is correct or not right and i
think this throws you an error i'm not
sure if this throws an error or just
returns or
you know
returns undefined
so it just it says that it returns you
jwt or string
so it does not return you a null value
yeah so i'm hoping that this throws you
an error anyway so if this does throw
you an error what you want to do is try
catch this block
and if we have a decoded token what i
want to do is the email should be
decoded dot email right
and what i want to do inside catch i
want to say that
you know console.log error first and
then rest.json
status invalid token
or you know status basically error let's
keep the format same error is invalid
token
right
but right here okay
yeah but right here
inside api code once we have the email
we can get the user and once we have the
user we can get the code so i can say
return status okay user not user but
code could be
user dot code right here which is inside
our model right so that's fine
that will work but you will see that we
also need to create the code right or
add the code so what we can do is also
create a post route
which pretty much again is authenticated
we verify the token we get the email but
the only thing which we say here is
update one email this and set the code
to be whatever we passed right so
request.body.code
which will destruct
from here
um status say okay and data is invalid
in other case awesome so i think that is
pretty much all we need from the back
end part yeah it should be probably
working just fine let's see it how we
can implement this on front end okay so
the first thing we want to do is you
want to say this is your code and let's
say this is code or
no code found
something like this
right and what i can do is make this
code
as a
state variable
which will help us
set this dynamically so once we have the
data i can save data dot status is okay
then i just want to set the code to data
dot
data i guess i think that's what we
return right
and go to index we can see slash api
slash code
hit ok and then the code
okay
so data dot code not data dot data
else i just want to say
alert data dot error right
all right so
here we have the basic setup for at
least displaying the code and right here
you can see the moment i refresh it we
get no code found because fair enough um
okay actually we are not returning
anything and the reason for that is
probably we missed rest.json
okay now if i refresh this you're gonna
see that again we get no code found
because okay
it saves me undefined as the alert
alert you can say see we just get status
okay the reason for that is because
user.code is undefined and undefined is
not json serializable so json just
removes this
so what we want to do is actually
provide
the user an interface to set the code as
well
the way we can do that is we can wrap
this whole thing inside of a div and
create an input field or rather a form
let's say input type text place on the
code
value is
empty port
set value is
you know
e
set m code
v
v.target.value
basic
state management stuff and you can just
go ahead and create this
like this
i also added a summit button and i also
am adding a handler to this which is
update code what this function will do
is it will just
send the same update
call
but this time you update the backend
right so i'm just going to say
the same thing right here
as populate but instead of the get
request we're going to be performing
post request and headers would be same
there would be one more body thing
right here and there would be a content
type header here as well application
json and the body would be
json.stringify
the following
thing which is quote as m code
right there and the final thing which we
can do is i mean we already have the set
code thing we can also say set temp code
as empty
and that will be
it i guess because we already have the
back end ready
on the server side
all right so if everything is fine
i do believe this application should
just work
out of the box now
so
or maybe not because we are missing our
input button i guess
or was it just a refresh away
yeah we have an alert of some sorts
not sure why
it's off populate code
for some reason
yeah and that is because we are not
using a weight
on request.json
so we just have a promise here and that
should not
be here as well there we go all right so
now it should work fine if i go ahead
and write a code something like
work today
or yeah okay so our code is not even
working
temp code and set encode
e dot target dot value
not sure if it was not working or
oh this is not set value on change i
think i should really go to bed
but anyway let's complete this video
work
today
party
later i don't know like i just randomly
created this and if i click on update
code nothing happens because we need
another final thing which is
to prevent this event from refreshing
the page
all right let's hope this works now
work today
party
later
update we send a code request
and we have another problem on backend
like yes
because i think we are still
yeah
i mean i'm always in the
graphql based mode right where you just
return the response and it sends us json
anyway so refresh now you can see our
code is updated
i mean
we know that it works but if i try to
add new code here
updated code
okay we get no code found
that is because of
why is that that is because of
let's see inside of date code we set the
temp code as that
and set code as
no this could be just temp code right
because we just sent the temp code so we
know that this will be the updated code
so refresh hey there
update code
and you see that we get hey there as the
code so i mean i think this will work
fine now if i go ahead and create a new
account if i go to register
may hold two enable to add the rate code
down dot com
and use the same password register and
log in again
login successful
okay i am able to
update the code and we get hey i'm able
to that's awesome now if i go ahead and
log in again but with my original
username and password hit login login
successful we still have hey there code
right and inside of the database when we
see and the database you can see that we
have a full more stack database and
inside that we have a user data
collection
where we have
all these records which we have created
right with the code values one final
thing i want to just tell you before
going from here is how you should store
passwords because that is i think super
important thing and usually people miss
out on videos like these so i don't want
to do that you should absolutely not
store passwords in plain text like this
the way to store passwords is the
following
go to your server folder and install a
package called yarn add bcrypt js
it could be bcrypt as well i'm just
using bcrypt.js because it is it does
not install binary binaries of bcrypt
which are native binaries and although
it's a little slower it just works like
that
but if you're writing it for the product
it's probably better to also consider
pcrypt as the package so bcrypt is a
hashing algorithm a hashing mechanism
which can
secure your passwords by making a
one-way hash of them so what do you want
to do
when somebody's trying to register is
you try to create a new password
by saying await vcrypt.hash
request.body.
password and give it some cycles and
usually 10 cycles are enough and you
store the hashed password instead of the
regular logged in password right so this
is the first step now the second step is
how do you verify this because the
moment somebody now tries to register on
your app
let's say if i try to create a maple
maple three at the rate codedown.com
and do the same thing what you're going
to see inside of database is that
mayhew3
right here
has a weird password right and this is a
hashed version of that password nobody
can know what the original value was
this is basically garbage at this point
but you also want to verify it right how
do you verify it so instead of
performing a request like this you find
the user
you know without the password and then
you say something like is password valid
again get a pilot to the rescue
bcrypt.com pair and you can see it
accepts two argument the first one is
the string and the second one is the
hash so the string is what we are
getting from the user so i'm going to
say request.password
and the second is the hash which is our
user.password right here
so now the equation becomes if the
password is valid because user is always
going to be valid more or less right
assuming that
you know you can even add a check like
here
return
status error
error
invalid login you know something like
that if you want
but yeah i mean once you do this it will
pretty much work like the same thing so
maybe at the rate codedown.com
you can see i get a login successful
one two three four five update
but in this case what we are doing is
now we are hashing this password in the
database so it's much more secure
why this is secure because in case your
database gets compromised then nobody
can really crack this password and know
the
real password of the user until they
haven't like really put a single digit
password which you also allow but anyway
the point is it makes it harder for
hackers and crackers to reverse this
password so always make sure that
whenever you're using any application in
production encrypt it with decrypt or
any good encryption library but yeah
that's pretty much it that is all it
takes to create your standalone mod
stack application with authentication
and that is all for this video probably
in some part two we'll be taking a look
at deployment of this application where
you actually deploy it on an ec2 or a
digital ocean so that is all for this
video i'm gonna see you in the next one
really soon
[Music]